[Music]
a desperate attempt to save lives
overstretched and overworked
medical staff at kharkiv regional
clinical hospital are under
unprecedented pressure
the intensive care unit is filled with
victims of this war
i haven't treated civilians with combat
injuries before i'm overwhelmed with the
amount of cases sometimes we receive 10
people from one location
but we've learned to do it quickly
provide aid it's our experience that
counts
they work under constant threat to their
own lives
[Music]
we're standing here and listening to the
sound of shelling i don't know where it
will hit the hospitals in balaclae and
zolachev are destroyed
in lazova
hospitals don't work anymore we don't
know what will be today if the bomb
lands the hospital will no longer exist
the children's hospital is destroyed the
center for blood donation operates from
the basement
many of these people were in their homes
when they were hit by shrapnel
the shelling was intense
then it stopped then it started again
three people were killed immediately i'm
the only one that survived but have all
these injuries
what are the kind of injuries that
you're seeing downstairs there are more
patients
sasha's leg has been amputated
you know actually there was a lot of
patient with the serious uh injures
right here but the this boy is the most
strong will from all of them because
most of them are crying asking for
saving their legs and
arms but he was the only one who said
just do what you
think you need to do
so
this is a real warrior still heart
and he has one message for the world
close the sky about ukraine and russia
these wards are filled with casualties
from this war
here most of patients are after
artillery
it's not because most of patients was
wounded by artillery it's just because
most of patients after aircraft are dead
so this is the most hard patient of uh
in another ward we find evgeny telashko
he threw his body over his
eight-year-old son when he heard
explosions his son was unharmed um
traveling above his chest and then go
out
here
he was struck by shrapnel the piece of
shrapnel that we see here we're shown
pieces of shrapnel by the staff
this tiny piece killed a woman
by staying here we are defending our
families and working for victory we are
together we are in a common cause this
is my bed
one
for the staff here this is their life
they sleep in the corridors to stay
close to their patients and hope the
walls will protect them if the hospital
is hit four
and you sleep in a car yep
patients like sasha and medical staff
here have all asked for the same thing
oblivious of the politics around it they
want the airspace of ukraine and the
city closed because it's the damage done
from the bombs that are dropped from
planes that are causing the most
casualties assad big al jazeera kharkiv